Привет! В прошлом уроке я показал типичную задачу от PM. Три строчки, ноль деталей. Сейчас разберём,
что с этим можно сделать. При обычном сценарии дизайнер получает размытую задачу и начинает
выяснять требования. Назначает встречу с протектом, тот рассказывает своё видение. Дизайнер уходит,
начинает работать, через пару дней понимает, что не хватает технических деталей. Зовёт
разработчикам. Ещё через неделю выясняется, что бизнес хотел другое. Новый созвон. Три-пять встреч
за две недели и на каждой что-то забыли. Всё равно к чему-то нужно будет возвращаться,
пока ты собираешь артефакты дизайна, у тебя возникают какие-то новые вопросы. В общем,
требования собираются случайно по кусочкам в разных чатах и заметках. Проблема, разумеется,
в самом подходе. В нём нет системности, нет структуры вопросов, нет понимания, когда информации
уже достаточно, а когда ещё нет. Метод, который мы разберём, решает именно это. Называется
рекурсивный брифинг. Суть метода в том, что тут есть три фазы и каждая отвечает за свой вопрос.
Фаза первая - это расширение вопросов, какие области задачи мы вообще должны покрыть. Вы даёте
агенту вводные, те самые три строчки, он читает и задаёт 4-5 вопросов, покрывающих всю ширину задачи.
Каждый вопрос из своей категории: пользователей, функциональность, технические ограничения,
UI/UX и бизнес. Это основные сферы, которые нужно закрыть и они будут отражены в нашем промпте.
Цель первой фазы - максимально широко обозначить территорию, в которой мы действуем и понять,
о чём вообще нужно думать. Вторая фаза - это углубление. Тут вопрос, где в ответ к дыре и противоречия.
Вы отвечаете на первый раунд вопросов, агент анализирует ответы и находит то, что осталось неясным.
Вы сказали, что, например, основные пользователи DevOps, а менеджеры тоже будут пользоваться или нет?
Если да, то им нужен тот же интерфейс или отдельный? Итак, два-три раунда.
После каждого - краткое резюме, что уже понятно, а что ещё нет.
Вот почему метод называется рекурсивным. То есть каждый ответ порождает более точные вопросы.
Отвечаем на сначала общие вопросы, а потом на более конкретные, тем самым всю область задачи мы покрываем.
И третья фаза - это консолидация. Вопрос тут, что мы знаем наверняка и что осталось выяснить.
Тут уже будут вопросы, на которые сам агент ответить не может.
Когда данных достаточно, агент собирает из всех раундов структурированный бриф.
Пользователи, сценарии, ограничения, метрики и отдельно список открытых вопросов.
Те вещи, которые агент не смог закрыть и которые вы пойдёте выяснять у продакта личного, отдела разработки или у кого-то ещё.
Один звонок на 10 минут вместо 5 встреч за 2 недели.
Теперь, как это работает технически?
Вся логика зашита в системный промпт. Я покажу его целиком и разберу по частям.
Промпт, как видите, небольшой сам по себе, но этого достаточно для того, чтобы этот брифинг проводить.
Сначала у нас цели, здесь они полностью описаны, что нам нужно сделать.
Это собрать полную картину требований для проектирования нового интерфейса на основе минимальных вводных от PM либо заказчика.
Результат - структурированный бриф, готовый к работе.
Следующая - это роль, кто как бы будет составлять для тебя весь этот бриф, задавать наводящие вопросы и так далее.
Тут эта строка будет меняться в зависимости от твоих задач, от сфер деятельности.
Мы чуть позже посмотрим.
Также здесь описана фаза расширения, то есть нужно прочитать вводные, задать 4-5 вопросов, покрывающих всю ширину задачи.
И разбиты эти вопросы по категориям: пользователи, функциональность, технические ограничения, UI/UX и бизнес.
Здесь уже для каждой категории отмечены ключевые моменты.
Для второй фазы углубления тут так все и расписано: ищи неполноту, противоречия и задавай follow-up вопросы.
И формат вывода: контекст продукта, целевые пользователи в табличке, ключевые сценарии, технические ограничения, UI-требования, метрики успеха,
открытые вопросы.
То есть мы сразу формат ему описываем, как мы должны получить результаты.
Ну и здесь дополнительно правила: вопросы, что порциями по 5-4, чтобы он не завалил этими вопросами.
Каждый вопрос с примером или вариантами ответа, чтобы упростить себе жизнь, а не наоборот искать ответы на еще большее количество вопросов.
Также, ну, чтобы он не давил, если ты говоришь просто "не знаю", бывает такое, что "не знаю", ну и что в бриф попадают только подтвержденные данные.
Вот здесь справа можете увидеть, я уже запустил исследование по задаче.
И если ты используешь именно расширение CloudCode, что здесь занимательно?
Он создает специально модальное окно, в котором выводит все варианты ответа, в котором удобно взаимодействовать.
То есть, ну, по сути, интерфейс кастомизируется под твои задачи.
Здесь я уже прошел первую фазу, фазу расширения, как вообще звучали вводные.
Лид прислал задачу "сделай дашборд для нашего сервиса по аренде VPS" и прикрепил к промпту файлик, просто его перетянув.
Он начинает задавать мне вот такие наводящие вопросы, собирать такие модальные окна действия VPS, ну, вот, сервера этого.
Какие мы можем предоставить клиенту: базовые, расширенные, там, модель оплаты по месячной, метрики.
Что для нас наиболее, что для нас важнее всего?
Ну, наверное, снизить нагрузку на саппорт пускай, и конкуренты, там, TimeWeb.
После каждого этапа он выдает summary, что уже понятно и что нужно выяснить, какие вопросы остались открытыми.
Вот я ответил на все его вопросы и получил финальный бриф.
Он у тебя будет в MD формате, так его читать не очень удобно, поэтому здесь правой кнопкой мыши нажимаем и выбираем Open Preview.
В самом брифе финальном есть контекст продукта, есть целевые пользователи, какая-то дополнительная информация специфичная для вот этой сферы.
Также есть ключевые сценарии, вот, например, у меня аренда серверов, тут вот управление WPS, биллинги и платежи, авторизация,
это все вот ключевые моменты, которые мы должны во Flow закрыть: технические ограничения, UI требования, метрики успеха,
открытые вопросы, на которые еще предстоит ответить, на которые сам он не ответит.
Например, набор доступных ОС для установки на WPS.
Ну, тут уже нужно в отдел разработки идти и спрашивать, какие они там будут предоставлять операционные системы на серверах.
Ну, и последний пункт - это scope. Здесь он написал, что надо сделать все, потому что я выбирал, что продукт должен быть полным с самого начала, не MVP.
Если бы это было MVP, он бы там обозначил, что сначала вот эти ключевые моменты нужно закрыть, а затем уже можно двигаться дальше.
И вот эта директива, она будет в описании под уроком, которую я показал, она адаптирована именно под B2B SaaS, облачные платформы, админки, дашборды.
Но метод работает с любым типом проекта, меняется всего несколько вещей.
Во-первых, роль. В зависимости от того, какую платформу вы разрабатываете, ну, нужен разный специалист, чтобы вам задавать наводящие эти вопросы.
Соответственно, мы меняем роль.
Если у вас e-commerce, то нужно, чтобы агент спрашивал про конверсию, корзину, каталог.
Если у вас там мобилка, нужно, чтобы спрашивал про жесты, push-уведомления, оффлайн-режим.
То есть, у каждого направления есть своя специфика и нужен тот специалист, который в ней лучше разбирается.
Если что, эта табличка, этот шаблон будет также у вас в материалах к уроку.
Дальше, категории вопросов.
На фазе расширения к категориям мы можем добавлять вот такие теги, исходя также из вашего типа проекта.
Для лендинга, например, бизнес категория важнее технической.
Логично, что таких вопросов должно быть больше.
Какой оффер, какая цель, какое целевое действие.
Ну и также, в зависимости от входных данных, что мы получаем на выходе, тоже можно дописать.
Например, просто полный бриф, либо бриф плюс карта воронки, плюс платформенные требования, плюс структура страницы.
Не так, что один раз мы эту директиву получили, скачали в материалах к уроку и переиспользуем вообще на всем.
Да, так будет работать, скорее всего, хорошо, но все-таки мы можем спокойно ручками чуть-чуть его дополнять и получать результат еще круче.
В материалах DZM будет список продуктов, вам нужно выбрать один из них.
С ним вы будете двигаться дальше по модулям.
Тут не будем делать жеребьевку, не будем никому насильно вручать какой-то конкретный продукт.
Будет список, выберите из него.
В качестве домашнего задания вам нужно будет провести этот бриф, отправить его результаты и также обязательно в самом начале указать, какой продукт вы выбрали.
Вам нужно сформулировать какую-то общую задачу на разработку этого проекта, либо какой-то фичи внутри него.
И не забудьте поправить директиву в зависимости от того, какой у вас продукт.
В следующем уроке нам все это понадобится.
Удачи с выполнением домашнего задания.
До встречи на следующем уроке.